un nutriólogo descubre que el número de
bebidas n que vende un restaurante de
comida rápida depende de la
concentración del azúcar cea en la
bebida de acuerdo a la fórmula nrc igual
hace entre 2 x 500 + 10 supón que la
concentración de azúcar depende de los
gramos de azúcar g en la bebida de
acuerdo a la fórmula se deje igualados
por g entre 50 usa la composición de
funciones para escribir el número de
bebidas vendidas n con una función de g
el número de gramos de azúcar por bebida
en el eje y aquí nos piden que
escribamos la fórmula después nos dicen
suponiendo que hay 15 gramos de azúcar
en una bebida cuántas bebidas de este
tipo se venderán y hay que redondear la
respuesta a enteros bueno para poder
encontrar la fórmula aquí en mi pizarrón
electrónico
he escrito estos datos que nos dan
tenemos el número de bebidas con
respecto a la concentración de azúcar
es esta fórmula y la concentración en
función de los gramos que es esta
fórmula entonces lo que nos están
pidiendo realmente es la función del
número de bebidas que es n lo pongo aquí
abajo el número de bebidas
pero como función de los gramos de
azúcar y está la tiene la función de la
concentración con respecto a los gramos
así que siempre que en esta fórmula del
número encontramos que vamos a
reemplazarla por esta expresión de aquí
abajo así que esto nos queda igual hace
pero se es 2 por g entre 50
y esto a su vez está dividido entre 2
qué es esta parte de acá y todo eso lo
multiplicamos por 500 por 500 y el
resultado le sumaremos 10
bueno vamos a simplificar esto esta
parte de acá 2 porque entre 50 entre 2
es lo mismo que tener esto entre 2 entre
1 sigue siendo 2 enteros pero esto me
permite que en lugar de tener esta
división pueda yo multiplicar esto por
el recíproco de esto de aquí abajo de
manera que me queda 2 g entre 50
por el recíproco de dos enteros es igual
a un medio y esto todo esto lo voy a
multiplicar por 500
y el resultado lo voy a sumar
con 10 bueno este 2 de aquí se va con
este 2 me queda gramos entre 50 es más
puedo seguir simplificando si yo divido
500 entre 50 me va a quedar 10 10 por 50
me da 500 así que todo esto se
simplifica como los gramos por 10 por 10
así es
para que se vea mejor puedo poner 10 por
gramos más 10 y esta es mi fórmula del
número de bebidas que se vende
dependiendo de los gramos así que todo
esto lo puedo expresar como mi función
del número de bebidas que se vende con
respecto a los gramos de azúcar que
contiene
y esto es igual a 10 por gramos más
ok ahora vamos a escribir esta fórmula
en nuestra página y escribimos la
fórmula que encontramos
en el eje es igual a 10 por g + 10 ok
esta es la fórmula pero además nos dicen
suponiendo que hay 15 gramos de azúcar
en una bebida cuántas bebidas de este
tipo se venderán pues lo único que
tenemos que hacer es este 15 ponerlo en
donde encontramos la g y simplificar la
fórmula 10 por g es 15 10 por 15 son 150
más 10 son 160 aquí van 160 bebidas
están en enteros no tuvimos aquí
fracciones así que nos quedó bien y
comprobamos la respuesta